I'll be Coimbra my name papa
it didn't and phrases [ __ ] yes they
updated it to 1.3 so now it doesn't
crashing I didn't have to replay all the
[ __ ] that the tree is looking what it's
not a tree breath alright that was
pretty [ __ ] creepy though
no let's not go in there ah [ __ ] me out
sir let's go in here I know nothing bad
is gonna happen by the fireplace
hi Brad hi Owen alright bread bread do
you want to be on the bed I'd run I'd
run bed that is this hands playing Karen
I'm blazer cool you like to play with
finger I like doing nothing all right
I don't have any tinderboxes I borrow
them what the hell I'd mushroom we got a
lute [ __ ] I got comment saying I don't
lose good enough oh look at that
that's what you get for telling me what
to do all right and the door over here
alright I just found the keys and maybe
nope what this a text say one of the
doors right all the way it doesn't have
a lock on it maybe there's now the way
miles there's no I don't [ __ ] my
sanity's just pissing me off
alright what about you know my left the
[ __ ] oh I'd spring all right perfect
ha come on stop stop let me get you out
yeah it's stuck
well I want the [ __ ] whatever I don't
care alright hello gentlemen I'm gonna
back out there come on well I'm sorry
I'm time time time I'm sorry I'm sorry
about your mom I'm not gonna all right
no boy no let's not go to Darrow ok well
what the [ __ ] up early I don't even need
that [ __ ] ah other way how about you
Thor boom but I don't know what I got so
many keys got more fit yes and potatoes
more Finn and potato that's one of my
favorite mixes it's really good I
suggest you try it on Sunday when you
have your friends over and your parents
maybe you feel like oh alright
no that doesn't work none of this [ __ ]
work come on
alright let's see what this goes behind
the boxes
oh you barrels trying to hide from me
come on try to hide doors for me come on
[ __ ] ups barrels you're not gonna stop
me I'm not stupid
all right there we go oh my god if
you're trying to get in the old side you
won't be able with just the key you had
an accident way and hadn't guessed badly
the guests do I don't know why you did
it or if he's working with the ballot
but he managed to find the key and enter
the old side he also matters his tumble
into the underground area where he
remained for an unknown time luckily we
were able to capture him before he could
tell anyone but just to be safe we had a
second blocking Mac kinda messed into
the door so use the key and then put all
the lever that's inside this room you
shouldn't know what it is you should
know where it is hopefully now I will
find both the key in the lever this time
alright so we need a key a lap lever and
Becks
might we don't eat bugs why would I need
your books Cal me hey hand
I either give me half I give me half I
well done and that small penises it
isn't alright
ah miles party gangbang again I told you
to stop doing that [ __ ] my sis miles oh
okay this one says three on it
this one says far on it alright
hey that you don't look too happy he's
wearing nice pair of boots and they
squeeze his head I don't like my head to
biess close wise whatever all right I
would love to know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing how I'm doing it why I'm doing it
why Brooks doesn't love me anymore and
that's it Shh
did you say something fireplace I don't
think yeah yeah yeah yeah I was a pity I
would lay in here all sexy and stuff and
you didn't see me what the hell going on
I mean yeah yeah come on Betty
let's go closer to the fireplace you
like my sexy hot body don't you oh who
is this touching my ass is that you pity
I have no it's not me I am finally pity
I knew you would cross over to the dark
side Oh appealing what are you doing
it's not me Peggy oh yeah I like there's
a lot I love that someone learned some
new moves
how would you oh yeah just go that pity
I like that a lot pity
thank you pity come here come and kiss
me there's nothing wrong with kissing
cute boys kissing is that gay telling
gays you think believe it's gave me God
what is that I didn't see that stupid
thing what is what is that doing there
what are you doing there oh no no I
didn't see yo it's not bad I didn't
[ __ ] see you what the [ __ ]
ah it is easy
fine fine fine fine fine fine fine
piano fine fine fine I don't care I
don't care
hi are you then small penis ha ha ha Oh
what you got it what I don't care I
don't care I can't battle think I care
see I'm a Takeru good job but uh uh Oh
blood
cool I'll go there oh oh wait doesn't
open oh I don't care I don't care I just
King I don't care I use a hammer I don't
care nothing [ __ ] it I don't owe a tree
in the [ __ ] basement I don't care a
crowler ok I care
Hector think it's gonna break it's gonna
all right oh my - rod like am i drawing
a button right my bad my bad my bad I'm
like my rowboat oh [ __ ] my from reading
you're gonna get dammit he was fastest
turnaround feel like eating like her you
get my ass
- ah bro no I'm kidding
bro if t they did here you can't be dead
bro bro bro wake up bro bro bro bro
somebody throw please
- Oh ro go back to life ro Oh bro so
many times you try to kill me
if it's gonna die it's kind of dead we
couldn't do it I don't hate a pity I'm
not now piggy what the hell is your
problem bro he's dead that's all right
maybe now I can probably use God
I meant the feeling he's gonna come back
don't worry he's gonna be back to rape
people all right damn use my a man
skills uh uh how about the [ __ ] come on
ah that's how I roll
that's how I get to the ladies I like
you you little [ __ ] all right huh don't
[ __ ] with me right now
Barrett don't talk to me sayonara [ __ ]
yes what I'm stuck
ah okay ha ha thought I was too fat
there for a second I'm not too bad let's
go down here I guess I don't know what I
feel about this
okay okay
its period again it's [ __ ] man you need
to check their period nice all right
let's go in here I recorded we're 20
minutes it's gonna be a ten minute video
as usual [ __ ] man's pissing me off
alright let's continue a little more I
like it I like you know Lord shake my
titties girl shake my shake my titties
girls a library down here decide really
how he meant it down here I'm Lily
alright whatever
that's pretty weird though I mean it
doesn't make claims I wouldn't really
put a library here this is just a dead
end that means it's not a dead end it
means more puzzles just make them stop
place this puzzles man Mouse Mickey tell
me where to go bro what is this lamp can
I rub you you can help me something's
gotta be like a secret book or some [ __ ]
or Jesus baby how you doing I like your
nipples Petey you can rub mine if you
want
Jesus you don't know how to be sexual
you know not always about tag all right
out here okay
it's gotta be something here some
[ __ ] secret that is yeah all right
whoa boy ah done that's time you got Oh
God done this ah that's better Jesus
guys you can't [ __ ] around right now
you need to find the other ones it's so
dark oh sorry sir - sorry founded once
again I'm sorry alright fine the other
one is Jesus listen up eyes fake books
just glowing guy and this is probably
this one those three no there's still
ticking okay they stop thinking of your
one one there was no one here right and
then was to here [ __ ] I have no memory
where are you I come on
oh yeah here yeah that's our ah ah
puzzle oh no I was sent dollars ago to
carry out the routine errands errands in
the gun ground area but I still haven't
figured out how to get through this room
scary down here is ridiculously high
it's a good thing we hardly use his
bride anymore if anyone from the skiers
I read this the lower dam secure that
eyes will be forced to take this Thomas
you don't want to [ __ ] with Thomas man I
bring some rat poison discussing me all
these rats everywhere ah some batteries
excellent there what are you doing here
yeah ah made me sneeze man ha
we're Stefano I'm not here bro let's go
it's not sticking
yeah this guy's afraid I've been I've
been watching you all this time
you have not learned a single [ __ ]
[ __ ] from us well I don't know I could
spin and [ __ ] alright more puzzle that
[ __ ] means alright let's go down here
oh sorry about that fun let's go what is
this more puzzles how could they have it
down here I don't know I don't really
care oh great just what I wanted
fantastic pity can torture carrucha
alright I'm nice let me love you tonight
and I'll make you all right I will
actually have to end this episode II but
your favorite you've been doing to crack
originally and I'll see you next episode
oh boy ever I'm Mike sales and booth oh
my god oh yeah didn't I get what let's
go let's go
haters gonna hate I laugh cuz you skate
this is not by fate because I hate your
mama put Oh what the hell